there is no legal definition of hate
speech in the United States and freedom
of speech is a fundamental human right
so the only world in which hate speech
would be defined correct me if I'm wrong
you're drawing a hypothetical you've
ignored the reality of where we are now
let me finish my friends first off I
wouldn't use that language you could be
fined for hate speech welcome back to
another installment of changed my mind
for those unfamiliar this is a segment
where I go on the street we take one
given topic and I just listen to people
let them change my mind we rationalize
our positions and it's usually really
productive we attempt to have a civil
dialogue sometimes people end up
changing their own minds and we'll show
someone in just a few seconds here but I
do want to show you something first it's
important to note that there are some
people out there who have no interest in
a rational discussion they will be angry
and volatile no matter what like this
guy do you would you like to have a
discussion or would you like to
interrupt and be contentious I'm trying
to listen like to be arrogant and not
hear anyone people say you're making
you're capable you're hurting you're
you're causing dysfunction in the world
said or you can have an intellectual
discussion cuz like I don't understand
no I understand exactly as you said
there's no definition of a human right
you really don't people who understand
and empathize with other people when
they say hey man you're really making me
uncomfortable and you're making my life
worse
yeah legally that's abuse on here they
don't make references to the law man
that's what matters no it's not like
what yeah it is
dude I'm literally autistic so okay I
can understand other people's feelings
better than you apparently really how
would you know that imagine if I run up
and I'm a real big jerk to you kind of
like you are right now
now even with that having occurred this
lady who could not disagree with me more
ended up having an entirely different
experience why do you question
well symbolizing male white male
privilege no I hadn't even thought of it
that way that what you thought when you
look at it I wondered so because I'm a
white male well it's just to fit the
sign it doesn't really mesh well with
the the peach skin tone as it were do
you a problem with white male privilege
yes no how so white white males have
destroyed this country I disagree would
you like to change my mind or present
have a discussion but Jane that could've
been better
sure Steven by the way Oh Terry oh sorry
I mean it was it you hurt your wrist
there okay oh oh you know I have that
too oh you do yeah I wanted to learn
piano too it's just gotta be chopsticks
yeah you know I've looked at the surgery
and it but I have to do another knee
surgery now so it's like I want it I got
to decide what I want working at the
time yeah fix your knee so you can walk
walk and then you can yeah walk to the
other surgery to have your wrist on you
know what's helped is I've gone to an
iPad from my laptop and so as opposed to
constant Mouse work doing this seems to
have helped quite a bit
well they mentioned what you said okay
so I imagine how different the world
would be or the country if women ran it
yeah if woman had been the ones in
charge okay when men had been the ones
fighting for suffrage
all those years you know but men were
the ones fighting for suffrage sure for
women are you aware that it was over
over 60% of women didn't want the right
to vote it was actually closer it was
like 70 something percent you know why
those in those mostly majority would
have been wealthy women right
no no a big reason why action we were
just talking about this with Naomi Wolf
is a because the right to vote was
actually low as a privilege it wasn't
just a basic right and so for men it
included the draft mandatory bucket duty
meaning fire fighting services and when
it was proposed it was okay women the
right to vote comes with these
responsibilities they didn't want it so
majority of women didn't want those
responsibilities so they didn't want the
right to to vote
want to wear the pants that was back
then yeah I mean we still want men to
treat us like delicate China yes well
back then historically you know so women
did get the right to vote but they
weren't a part of the draft they didn't
have to perform on the firefighting
service
I'm not saying by the way that women
shouldn't have the right to vote I'm
just saying it's looking through today's
lens of history for nothing it's like
all right ladies you want this well this
goes with it I mean right we can also
tell you that you can be drafted just as
easily as weekend guys that's something
you'd support women in in the draft yeah
yeah okay sure absolutely
oh sorry well you know I yes
I just hate speech is not a thing it
doesn't exist and anyone can change my
mind do you disagree
what about like racism and stuff you can
all cut you can all come in and discuss
by the way it said that what is hate
speech
okay what's the legally but hate speech
right what's the legal what is hate
speech what's the legally defined term
what does it mean it doesn't exist it
does in my country of Canada or in
Europe where you can be jailed for
saying offensive things but in the
States the First Amendment protects
against that so the question I was
raising Canada yeah I live here now
thank God really well why don't you go
to Canada I just came here I wanted to
come and I came why don't you go to
Canada then why really free health care
right yeah you'd have to what would what
is uh what is free about health care in
Canada what are you paying taxes here in
the States
I like like all my paycheck is really
small so so you didn't pay okay
so right now you're fundamentally not
paying taxes so what if I were to say
you know that your tax is over your
taxes are over half your marginal income
tax right you're paying 14 percent sales
tax and you still have to pay for 70% of
the drugs and services you want in
Canada and the wait times are bad as a
matter of fact there are fewer they're
really bad yeah so if you want to move
therefore just free health care also by
the way they're not super friendly to
immigrants um put the health care
doesn't include you guys right off the
bat yeah they're actually much stricter
on immigration than the United States it
includes it includes people coming in
there haven't paid enough time into the
pool right no no they're not it's just
you know when you're talking about a
socialized health care safety net a lot
of you law understand sort of a the
asterisks that comes with it yeah
exactly you know so she's entering you
hear a lot of people say they want to
move to Canada so you would be okay with
like Canadian law where you can be
jailed for quote unquote hate speech or
fined yeah well it is passed a bill
where you can actually depending on how
you read it legally you can be fined or
you can be jailed for misusing gender
pronouns for someone who's transgender
mm-hmm you can be punished for that
legally I mean at that point right
legally it's either it's illegal or it's
not so then it becomes is it by accident
is on purpose
either way is it something that should
be a punishable offence
okay so we said that we've said that's
not hate speech so in other words
they're trying to break down the First
Amendment rights in Canada well they
don't have a First Amendment no other
country has a First Amendment outside
the United States yeah free speech
doesn't exist outside the United States
Lobby people don't know that so are we
willing to trade that if speech is
offensive I say no but I'm willing to
hear any arguments that change my mind
that's all you know even if we disagree
on let's say everything I think it's
important to listen to what an opposing
point of view us to say in other words
we can just you're trying to define hate
speech is just in the same category as
all speech yes First Amendment yes so
and it's you're right it doesn't make it
ethical of course it doesn't mean of
course you could say something very
offensive for example very racist that I
would disagree with horribly but it's
speech you have the right to say it
and I have the right to be offended if I
want I have the right to disagree with
it
I have the right to argue why you're
wrong but I don't believe that we have
the right to shut downs anyone's speech
based on a term like hate but I'm open
to hearing convincing arguments on hate
speech don't mention when you say
something like microphone was on get a
couple wild turkeys in you all of a
sudden you're talking about making
America great again you never know what
comes out yeah I've seen it but you're
not pro Trump that's an interesting
question I'm actually more of a
libertarian I am definitely a
conservative having moved to the States
leaving a socialist country I'm not a
huge fan of Trump individually mm-hmm
yeah well I mean I'm Pro free speech I'm
Pro Second Amendment
I'm Pro limited government I don't I
don't really know what Trump is any of
those policies but for example looking
at his recent tax proposal I would
support that I would support beat coming
from a family of legal immigrants I
would support ensuring our borders
making sure that we're secure well of
course allowing people to immigrate here
legally so certain policy I've
definitely lined up more with him than
say like
Hillary Clinton or Bernie Sanders but I
don't I don't really like him
right because it's there's a few facts
about trumpet that are bothersome to me
yeah the fact that I expect that because
many presidents before him especially
even Michelle Obama had a PhD Barak had
a PhD that's the highest position in the
country wouldn't you think we would
expect at least the person to be that
well educated you have a PhD he's got a
bachelor's and his dad probably paid for
it right we pretty much know that come
on command not to mention yeah go ahead
so I was gonna ask you a question
who would you say or just you don't have
to pick any one specifically but list
who would you say were the best
presidents like throughout history from
George Washington up until today who
would you pick who are your personal
favorite my personal favorite is Abe
Lincoln okay did he have a PhD I do not
know is it possible that Abraham Lincoln
read in a shack by candlelight a very
little formal education you tell me did
he yep yeah I'm saying
friggin that's the case is you're saying
that my only my only contention there is
that a PhD doesn't make anyone smart or
unintelligent I've met people with PhDs
who are moronic I've met people who
never graduated high school who are
brilliant yeah it's not to say you're
wrong if you're if you your
presuppositions that President Trump is
unintelligent it's not arguing that but
I don't think that a PhD is a fair
determining parameter and based it seems
on your own preferences we probably
agree on that
yeah unless you possibly unless you look
at the fact that educational
opportunities were not as easy for
people for press presidents as they
might benefit Trump especially since
Trump has enough money mm-hmm you know
to have gone that far and that has
stifled his maturity I believe I mean
he's sorry but he's a toddler I mean he
is he's immature
I think he's emotionally immature I
would I would agree on that I'm a
therapist okay
so clinically speaking
is mentally ill it's not stable doesn't
wander the White House yeah but we can't
necessarily forbid him from the White
House that people voted for them right
just based on that yeah but I don't
acknowledge knows my president you don't
know I go was that because he's not
representing what I feel are is valuable
okay values okay but he is the president
legally and like I feel like every
stupid opportunity that he has like the
like going to Puerto Rico throwing paper
towels it's like PR stunts yeah and his
his rhetoric he's doesn't I mean what do
they hear the other day he said he was
looking to speak to the president of the
Virgin Islands or something like that
yeah understand his his horizons aren't
open so it'd be safe to say that you're
probably more left you're liberal I am
okay but I guess on this it sounds like
we agree you support the further
Al Franken for resident okay sounds like
we agree though on on this on the idea
of the first amendment and no
limitations on freedom of speech we have
to because when we start putting those
limitations we're gonna be like when uh
we're gonna be needing Amnesty
International step in and save our ass
right I mean so you're pretty something
that yeah you're pretty right leaning on
that libertarian on that does it bother
you at all that your your party that who
you support the DNC people like Al
Franken there's a lot of proposed
legislation on speech that they support
hate speech laws does that concern you
and also of course culturally I'm sure
you're aware liberals obviously are far
less tolerant of speech they disagree
with but on the legal side would you be
for example opposed to any legislation
that would impede on someone's speech I
would okay would you vote for it left it
left its leading it even though you know
that's ironic because
hillary-bernie Warren Graham he's not
politics it's no sure I'm actually very
interested to hear your opinion on that
because you know you would know more
about the pathology behind that and
seems like you agree with seems like we
find common ground even though I'm an
evil right wing privileged white male
from Canada and you're more liberal well
it's interesting that that's something
they get behind because if they're you
know if the liberal left-wing view has
always been you know free free thinking
mm-hmm and you know free to be who you
are and you know gay rights and all this
stuff right immigration and you know Pro
immigration why wouldn't we still
welcome that freedom to express
ourselves right you know because I'm
sure and you never want to think that it
would start to spread in that regard to
right we could be stifled by our ability
to express ourselves in that particular
manner okay and we have it be tyrannical
yeah it be I mean defined or looked at
or sure you know so let me ask you this
oh I see a message in this it's haste so
take it off the wall right you're
arrested for I know yeah
well that way right exactly let me let
me ask you this kind of final question
cuz I want I know you have to go on your
merry way here today let me ask you this
if you will do now do maybe after this
conversation a little more research into
candidates you support regarding their
positions on freedom of speech yeah
because I didn't know Al Franken was
well let's say whoever it is whether
it's Bernie Hillary Clinton would you
look into it more and let's say it were
a candidate who supported some form of
hate speech laws or constrictions in the
First Amendment would you consider not
voting for them even though they were a
Democrat see that was nice not
everyone's this guy
imagine we change a First Amendment yeah
and then we pass a law saying that
that's behaviors heat speech right is it
now hates that would be a violation of
Human Rights and I wouldn't support it
thank god there's no law like that that
exists wonderful imagine that we did it
but here's the thing you're not your dad
you that we did it connect can I can i I
just answered your question I imagine
that we did it because there's no legal
definition of it right I'm saying
imagine if there was a legal definite
yes yeah
i William Denby hates me no no it would
be a violation of Human Rights and I
wouldn't support a violation okay so you
don't support hate speech laws I do okay
I'm hearing you say that whether or not
something hate speech hinges on whether
or not it's legally defined know it what
I'm saying is yes there is no legal
definition of hate speech in the United
States and freedom of speech is a
fundamental human right so the only
world in which hate speech would be
defined correct me if I'm wrong you're
drawing a hypothetical you've ignored
the reality of where we are now let me
finish my friend first off I wouldn't
use that language you could be fine for
hate speech did you enjoy this video
here's the thing you wrote you're here
this is the end of it so we don't care
cuz you already watched it but if you
really didn't like it and you want to
justify it leave a comment below telling
us why you didn't like the video and if
you liked us let us know and subscribe
to the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright